Nếu đậu nghĩa an suốt ngoại đứng đầu các đứt năm 2018,
chào sủy lượng mà cuộc lĩnh xíc vụ quả sao với công bố,
mười địa phương có số lâu động sang nước ngoài làm việc dương nhất năm 2018,
thì nghe an đứng tương nhất, hòa sân vĩ cơ Việt Nam năm 2018,
sau cuộc lĩnh xíc vụ quả sao công bố quả tháng người,
cũng sẽ tổng kém mức tuy nhất từ các tị trường trong điểm
lâu được Việt Nam đáng làm việc, tính chào nơi đi,
đong bằng xong hông vự bệnh tình thành bao công hại dương,
hương yên, năm định, hành lời, khái định, định định định,
hài phòng sẽ đầu cả nước với hợp 3,5 yên xấu trong người,
theo sau là bóc Trung bộ,
ở sinh thải miền Trung với năm tình,
thình hóa, nghĩa an,
hả tính, khoảng biệt, khoảng chiếc,
hơn 300,5 năm trong năm 2019,
lâu được làm việc tại hành Quốc cho tuy nhất có nhất là một yên xấu trong đến 2 yên
đoạn đe quế đến là dịch bản,
một yên 2 trong đến 1 yên năm trong WTD,
lại lên Trung Quốc 3 trong đến 1 yên 2 trong WTD,
một số cuộc gia châu Âu có mức tình tự,
ký trường Trung đông và Malaysia gìi nhận mức lượng thấp hơn,
khoảng 6,5 yên đe quế lâu được có tình yên,
và bốn trong lịch 6 trong WTD mỗi tháng với lâu được vũ thông.